welcome to martinique
ils voyageaient à bord de deux navires
de luxe
le sea cloud et ce magnifique trois
mâles le royal clipper une clientèle
fortunée que les arlésiens attendent
chaque saison alors quel est leur
programme à terre on va à la plage et en
profitent de ce joli sable on va faire
du snorkeling depuis la plage et ensuite
on doit rentrer pour 13h je crois alors
nous n'avons qu'une demi-journée le
front de mer est accueillant ce matin
mais seuls 2 croisiéristes prennent le
temps de boire un verre au bord de l'eau
et ils sont rarement plus nombreux qui
concerne les activités sur la plage de
grand-anse n'y participent pas quelques
petites consommations de ci de là mais
vraiment aucune retombée concrète et
visible quoi et voici l'explication
selon ce croisiéristes allemand et à
tant de choses dans sur le bateau à
manger à boire
il ne faut pas boire ici c'est un petit
peu plus aventuriers que les américains
ou un peu plus ce matin de nombreux
croisiéristes sont partis à bord de
grands autobus en excursion vers la
pagerie et l'habitation clément ceux qui
ont choisi la plage ne se hasardent
guère à tester les nombreuses activités
nautiques à disposition comme aller voir
les tortues plongée ou essayer le step
up paddle
les touristes sont va diriger vers les
bus ou alors ils ont déjà des excursions
prédéfinis qui sont achetés sur les
bateaux de croisière donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué et il reste pas forcément
très longtemps non plus au début quand
on est un novice sur la plaque on a
commencé on sait déjà c'est trop bien et
à tout le monde et tout sera rentré bien
mais au final est bien que l'on soit
dans le sud certains croisiéristes font
appeler des taxi pour se rendre à
l'appeler ou en forêt profitez de la
rivière par exemple parce que la mère
des fois il en a un petit peu assez
et comme lamartine et que les buts et
être l'île aux fleurs île verte donc ils
veulent découvrir si cet aspect ou delà
de tout ça je pense que le véritable
intérêt de la croisière aujourd'hui
c'est de pouvoir tron va dire
transformer des croisiéristes en futurs
touristes ces gens de les faire revenir
et puis de montrer la différence avec
les autres îles anglophones que ce soit
notre
contre french touch mais notre cerveau
en faire peu importe mettre notre
culture en argent ans d'art les trois
ilets marin la saison dernière 60000
croisiéristes ont fait escale dans le
sud mais difficile de savoir combien
envisagent vraiment de revenir aux
locations four à l'hôtel